how's it going Brad's disappeared today
we're playing a very very special game
Bowl
don't be nervous talking to girls how to
play don't care the goal of each
challenge will be to get my number and
to make a new friend okay I don't care
Wow whoa hey this is me walking around
town alright first let's go to the park
I can't wait I like to play hard-to-get
so I can use me your seat how is it my
seat it has my name on it we know before
I call the police
what why would she call the police
sorry like a button to just blow her up
that would be great the strangers
attacking me alright fine I just wanted
to talk to you okay
here's your chance my name is Jessica my
name is I don't give a [ __ ] get off my
seat my name is full of chicken 44 my
name is poo poo head they're equally bad
it's good to meet you how many times
does your heart beat in a day how many
time this is my heartbeat in a day are
you she's serious she actually wants to
know the average why because you just
made mine skip a beat how corny was that
we're gonna keep playing but if she
pulls a [ __ ] like that again I'm not
playing any [ __ ] water right you only
have five seconds to remember a [ __ ] oh
god ah [ __ ] son of a I got Grady hey
I'll take it this game is so much fun
sage to coffee-shop
no but you should I don't think so can I
take a seat
sure why not I'm a [ __ ] Casanova baby
I have to find out something for a
friend
what is the birthstone for the month of
May like she expects me to know it I
don't [ __ ] know emerald thanks for
your help
so no something like that how does
someone like me oh I'm sorry
oh I'm sorry I'm not cultivated enough
for you judge so much I knew a few
things I know a few things you can do
better than that you can do better than
everything shut up I'll call you please
don't okay I'm a wizard man all right
I'm sorry what's the answer to this
[Music]
really I think you're pretty cool no one
thinks you're cool Jessica I like okay I
can pause the game thank God for that
option don't know what I'd do without it
all right now we can do the amassment
park greetings from Planet Earth
what oh I'm sorry there's no gigs
allowed at the amusement park you must
have missed the sign [ __ ]
that's one tall rollercoaster stupid
thing is that's one tall rollercoaster
over there hey you want to go home too
mean [ __ ] Wow you know your coasters I'm
in pain oh you're high all right no your
coasters bros no your coasters and your
name has to be full chicken 44 it looks
like we have a lot in common no we had
nothing nothing in common
I'm not gonna buy her a drink what if I
don't want to I don't drink
thank you oh thank god okay I'm just
trying to be friendly well try to be
friendly somewhere else you're smelling
up the place with your bad
conversational skills
well you know what [ __ ] you too then I
don't drink but thank you you're the
most uninteresting person I have ever
met I'm not even gonna bother I press
don't try so goddamn hard if you want to
impress I'll talk to a girl or a boy or
an alien dinosaur I don't know this game
is redonkulous
but I'll be enjoyed watching leave a
like if you did hit subscribe come read
today and I will see you in the next one
[Music]